[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
55
stream yes i've reorganized the words in
order to make live 55 work because it's
is that alliterative uh alliterative no
no
it's rhyming it's an internal rhyme all
right
forgive me well anyway here you are and
here we are
if that's the only thing they need to
forgive you for i'd say we're ahead
all right i would like to assert that
that is the only thing that they have to
forgive me for and we'll just
go from there excellent all right
perfect
so today we are going to talk a little
bit about um
a study that came out about covert 19
that got into the press
and alarmed a number of people including
us um
no i wouldn't say that no i was alarmed
i was alarmed that something was amiss
based on the uh the claims so our friend
dave um
who who made that beautiful who made
both the uh
the lit logo here and the knife in the
background
um alerted me i had not heard of it and
said
i suspect something's wrong here anyway
we're gonna talk about that
uh and we're gonna talk about the
queering of mir
of muir woods and the national park
service and the
uh simultaneous in time lgbtq stem day
hashtag lgbtu stem day and what that
means
about our future i want to end with
giving a little bit of gratitude and i
think there's a few other things we want
to talk about
here and there in between does that
sound like what we had planned
that sounds exactly like what we had
planned all right um maybe
actually maybe we should start by saying
um
that uh our patreon our private q a our
private two and a two hour
q a uh will be not tomorrow not this
sunday but next sunday and right after
this
live stream i will be opening up the
48-hour window for the questions
that people at a certain level my
patreon can ask and
we prioritize the questions we don't get
through all of them but we spend a lot
longer on the questions that get asked
in the private q a than we
have time for in these public ones um so
consider joining us there
and the cues have been excellent thus
far yeah they really they they really
are and quite diverse
um uh tend towards um a lot of them
are are sciencey which is which is
wonderful
yeah exactly all right shall we start by
talking about this
this study let's do it all right uh
let's see
maybe we start first by showing
um just this this headline zach
so this in the daily mail dog owners
face 78 higher risk of catching covet
wow this is an ad riff yeah
dog owners face 78 higher risk of
catching cover 19 and home grocery
deliveries double the risk study fines
um that's the headline okay
there are a number of headlines that uh
that looked a bit like this
uh also among headlines you know
screamed from the headlines
masks don't do any good but uh but
cleaning your groceries when you get
home does that sort of thing
so this sounds both alarming
and also really inconsistent
with a lot of what we have come to
understand
yeah just a reminder for those who have
come
to our our live streams our podcast
since
the end of may when we started we
started on march 24th i think was our
first one
specifically to talk about covet and our
first 16 or so episodes were almost
entirely about covid
and we really walked through some of the
some of the evidence that was coming out
for what was true about it and
some of the politicizing of it and all
of this and
you know this result if true this set of
results if true
really goes counter to so much of what
we think we understand
yeah and so for those who've been around
from the beginning of our live streams
you watched our model develop and indeed
at the very beginning we were quite
concerned about what are called fomites
which are
viral particles that are transmitted um
on surfaces which is a very common way
for viruses to be
transmitted but it became clear over
time that that was less prevalent
in uh in the case of covid and so this
study
uh a presumably people walking their dog
are doing it outside
that should be fairly safe pacing their
dog
pacing their dog around their kitchen
island yeah all right i mean
but so anyway there's something weird
about you know alarm over
uh walking the dog there's something
weird about the idea
that having stuff delivered to your
house
is dangerous of groceries groceries
being delivered to your house
uh appears to have contained within it a
greater risk of contracting covert than
going out grocery shopping for yourself
right right that's one of the results as
well
seems to make little sense because
having them delivered to your home
eliminates whatever confined spaces you
might face
uh in the grocery store or in
vehicles or whatever um so anyway
there's a lot here that raises alarm
bells either
the um either the study is in some way
flawed
or the model that we have been building
up
is deeply flawed and so anyway yes it uh
it does raise exactly that question yeah
uh i'm sorry my computer
is not behaving yeah thank you
there we go thank you um
let us if you would show this for just a
moment zach this is the actual paper
um it has a publication date for those
who read
publication dates of 2021 just meaning
that here is the
uh is the early publication online but
it is
it has been peer reviewed it is due to
actually be published in this form
early in 2021 with the headline the
spread of sars kobe 2 in spain
hygiene habits sociodemographic profile
mobility patterns and comorbidities
okay let me walk us through
just a little bit about what they tried
to do before we talk about some of the
results
uh and i guess you know spoiler alert
it does not seem that we should be
overly concerned about the results
screaming from the headlines as a result
of this research because
i at least have very little faith that
these results are going to end up being
meaningful having now
spent some time with the paper itself so
for a few reasons
the methods were a survey an online
survey
of people's activities that is
self-reports um
self-reports are often somewhat
unreliable people remember different
things that are
than are actually true but fair enough
it's a fairly common
um social science mode um however
basically encouraging people whoever
feels i get to go online
is um and and fill out a survey is
not the most rigorous way of getting
self-reports from people of having
people take a survey and the survey was
taken
or was um was asking about the period of
most intense
lockdown in spain so everyone remembers
um this
early early mid spring when spain
and parts of italy were in such high
lockdown that people weren't were
really discouraged even from leaving
their homes right um so
this is all of the results if they are
trustworthy based on these self-reports
are about a period during which
all of the most intense methods of
transmission
as far as we understand the virus had
already been eradicated right so there
was
there was no there was um very little
working in offices although there was
some there was discouraging of
um of social events there was you know i
think basically complete cut
shutdown just as in most of the us of
most of the retail sector except for
essential businesses
and so that that alone need
forces us to recalibrate our estimate of
what something like a 78
increase in a risk of contracting a
virus
when walking your dog say would mean
because that 78
increase is compared to a rate that has
already been drastically reduced
by the fact of the lockdowns that the
government has imposed
that's true that's just something to be
aware of when thinking about how to
calibrate
internally what these numbers might mean
but here's the point
in the paper where i really started to
question whether or not we should be
believing anything in this
it's in the statistical analysis so
quote
considering that the capacity of
diagnostic tests in spain was not
sufficient
two affirmative categories were
introduced one of them was affirmative
by diagnosis
and the other by patient self-report
what that means in english as opposed to
sciences
is in order to assess so that you know
they ask people did you walk your dog
did you take the metro
did you you know did you work from home
all of these things and then
separate they also asked everyone did
you or did you not have coven
and those people who ended up at the yes
i had covered column ended up there by
one of two ways either they had an
actual diagnosis from a test
or they said yes i suspect i had coven
yes i suspect i had covid is
indistinguishable within the results of
this study from
yes i had a test and um and it came back
positive for covid
and not only that not only are those two
categories which are
wickedly different um combined and
impossible to untangle in these results
but fully half fully half of the
affirmative cases
are coded as self-reports all right so
a number of things one wonderful
teachable moments in here
yeah so many one thing to say is that
were it the case that self-reports and
self-diagnosis
were random in their
nature then all that you would need to
do to correct for the problems of them
being
important to the methodology of the
study is have a larger data set
the problem and increasingly this is
something i think a huge fraction even
of the
educated sophisticated part of the
population is not grocking
is that everything changes when you have
a systematic error
rather than a random error a random
error
sounds worse in some ways because um
you can't fix it right you can't ever
get rid of them it sounds like it's very
uh destructive
of data but really the point is it just
it's like a noisy restaurant where
somebody's talking to you it's it's
random
stuff and you can find the signal
through it and increase your sample as
you just said increase your sample size
in order to
decrease the effective random error
that's how you do it right
the problem is systematic error
especially systematic error that you're
in no position to estimate
creates a whole different problem and it
does not go away with a bigger sample
size in fact it can get worse
um you can reinforce the sense that
something is there that isn't
and so the question is how likely is it
in a world
where people are self-diagnosing that
their tendency to self-diagnose
incorrectly is correlated to some other
thing
in their personality right their
tendency to report that they've walked
their dog when they haven't right maybe
you know who knows what it will be
correlated to but the chances
that it is a random factor are low and
we are in a very poor position to say
what else it will be correlated with
and therefore one has to worry that
there might be false signal in here
rather than just a bunch of noise
yeah and the numbers aren't aren't that
big
so even if some of the error is random
uh we
we should expect that it will actually
be conveyed here as well
yeah um okay so
with regard to the results like all of
those those
oh hold on so we've got um it's a survey
not the actual known data on what people
were really doing we've got self reports
where people we know
will lie about things that make them
look to the outside or feel better
inside about themselves it is about a
moment in time when the most extreme
lockdown was happening
and therefore when people were in fact
the most worried
and the most confused and the most
alarmed and probably the most likely to
mistakenly self-diagnose
right and the statistical analysis
itself the way
that positive um that positive
covid diagnosis is assessed is is deeply
suspect
all of that said we can talk about the
results knowing that maybe the results
don't mean anything like what they
what they say they made and i and i
intend to but you wanted to say
something yeah i wanted to say something
which is just
um as a scientifically sophisticated but
not
uh expert in this particular area
person i would say one thing that is a
red flag for me
is that it's hard to imagine a mechanism
whereby walking one's dog increases
transmission
assuming that i've got a couple i've got
a couple possible so i've thought this
through two and i've come up with some
stuff that might work
um and in fact would match some errors
i've seen elsewhere so we'll come back
let's see if we've got the same stuff
let's just let's just kind of spell this
out before we go into the details
in a little while which is that okay if
if you have a result that you trust
the next thing you do is um in this case
would be well
well why then what you know what is the
mechanism you know that's surprising
again we don't think this is a
legitimate result i i don't anyway
but if it's true then the next question
should be why
does walking the dog cause an increase
in
in covert risk and from there you would
want to posit all the possible
hypotheses and then test
them so it's an addition it's not it's
not going back and replicating the
original data that you tried to take but
it's now testing
a new observation that is the result of
a previous scientific test
um to figure out to get more granularity
on the y
on the mechanism of why the result is
what you think it is again that all
hinges on the idea that the initial
result is true which
i don't see any reason to think that it
necessarily is right and i'm not saying
that there's
any way that you can look at a result
like that and say it's too surprising to
be true
we can come up with various you know
shocking ways that it could be true and
sometimes shocking things do turn out to
be true but
my point would just be okay i've walked
dogs
okay i have some sense of what that
typically looks like and i don't have
any reason to think that my experience
walking a dog
is particularly unusual a people
tend to do it during the day i'm not
saying 100
but maybe it's 80 percent right so uv
light they tend to do it outside
right they tend when they interact with
other people
one is often at a distance because
you've got dogs and a leash circling
each other whatever so it's not like
you're right up in each other's faces
when you talk to somebody that you meet
while walking the dog all of these
things should tend to keep rates of
transmission very low
rather than make them high um and you
know
particularly conspicuous is just the
fact that outdoors seems to at least so
far during the pandemic have been
terrifically protective
even at night even when there's no uv so
you would need some other kind of
mechanism now i'm curious what did what
did you come up with
in terms of possibilities if this result
was right a couple of things
one excuse me is um actually goes a
little bit counter to what you just one
of the things you just said which is
that um
especially during a time of social
lockdown early on when people still hope
that it was maybe you know a month or
two
but we're really going out of their
minds as as people are again of course
um with suddenly being socially isolated
uh walking your dog and seeing a
neighbor or seeing someone
you know even whom you don't know but
whom your dog you know someone else is
walking their dog and your dog wants to
meet them
this is a perfect excuse even for the
for the most
coveted concerned you know even for the
most hawkish among us
uh uh with regard to covid uh to
let the dogs sniff each other and
perhaps get a little bit closer than you
should and to have a little conversation
and if in addition uh neither of the
people walking their dogs are wearing
their masks because it's outside why
would you
uh and you do not you know in a moment
when you're actually talking with that
person
um put on a mask then there may well be
a possibility of transmission there
that said there was a result from you
know many i think tens of thousands of
people
out of china early on that i talked
about in one of our first episodes
that showed that across tens of
thousands of cases where they could
track transmission literally
one of them was trackable to an outside
interaction now it was an outside
interaction
between neighbors talking right right so
so there's there's that possibility
which is
um which i think is not very likely but
i you know i have i did at one point not
walking a dog but have a drink outside
with a friend actually nancy rommelman
um at some point you know in the late
summer
and we were sitting across from each
other at a table outside and the sun was
coming in
sufficiently that i could see as if
either of us talked
and like spittle would come out of our
mouth like oh
maybe we should be sitting on the same
side of the table physically closer
but whatever is coming out of us is
going to go not into each other's drinks
or whatever
our noses but actually away from one
another so i do think that um you know
close close facing each other outside
and talking
is going to be a better route for
transmission than sort of being side by
side that's one thing
and then there's of course the
possibility that there's dog to dog
transmission and dog-to-person
transmission
and there is not evidence of this yet
but there is
um some suggestive evidence that it
might be possible
and hold on specifically not just people
walking their dogs and meeting other
people walking their dogs
um but this research did not ask about
whether or not if you walk your dog you
also took your dog to a dog park
and so dog park is going to be and i
can't think dog park now without
thinking about that rape and dog parks
paper that the grief and studies people
put together but
um you're a going to be in a much more
social situation both with people and
with dogs and if there is transmission
between dogs and dogs to people then
that would be
a pretty good place for it to happen so
okay
so this this gets tangled here because
the fact
were transmission from dogs to people
um not just possible let's grant that
even if it has never happened it might
still be possible
sure but were it a route
that was likely then we would
certainly have had lots of opportunity
to discover it
because there has been lots of interest
in dogs and cats and they're contracting
covid and in epidemiological circles
what transmits to what is a very
important factor so the point is it's an
obvious question now that doesn't mean
people have looked at it but i will be
shocked if nobody has looked into the
question of
uh dog to person transmission and so if
this paper is detecting
dog to people transmission um well again
this paper is completely agnostic on
that
right that's my point if it's detecting
it without specifying it as a mechanism
that's a remarkable
thing and again
the the thing that is most glaring here
is how robust
the this doesn't seem to transmit
outdoors result
is and the fact that it would have to
transmit outdoors here either between
people walking their dogs or dogs to
people
something has to be happening and that
is so contrary to
the model that has developed and
robustly so because of course the
question
of protests and whether they were going
to create a massive
wave um and the fact that they don't
seem to have which you and i
said i i will be careful about saying we
predicted it but we did say
there's a strong possibility they won't
because these things tend to be outdoors
and for whatever reason
probably multiple reasons outdoors does
not appear to be consistent with uh
spreader events yeah so did you have
what did you generate was it was it like
what i did or what did you generate with
regard to possible mechanisms if this
result is true
yeah and walking your dog actually is
associated with an increased risk of
contracting covet as opposed to not
having a dog or not walking your dog at
all which is which was
those were the lumped categories um what
other mechanisms that we haven't yet
talked about to degenerate
i was wondering so in a prior case which
i was unable to
find um but there was a an alarming
um report of a paper that suggested
spreader events at protests or
uh at maybe it was beat parties or
something like that
and i was i thought oh my god has this
thing evolved to be transmissible
outdoors which is one of the things you
and i have worried about that it doesn't
transmit outdoors but it could learn
that trick if we're not
careful and in any case i went to the um
paper and it was like oh there was no
evidence it was being transmitted
outdoors there was some other
phenomenon that was lumped in here that
involved
indoor contact between people right
so in this case i was wondering if under
lockdown conditions walking one's dog
resulted in something like
you know going into a coffee shop right
now maybe
coffee shops weren't open at that time
but i was imagining that there might be
something
that people who were outside because
they were walking their dog
were doing that wasn't outside that
could be some route
well i think uh if i can pull it up here
i think oh actually i have it on
um paper i think that's unlikely to be
true just because
um where what kinds of
retail outlets people went into is in
here and
they don't ask coffee shop but they ask
have you been to a supermarket green
grocery butchery bakery
pharmacy tobacco shop bank
medical care center uh and for none of
those
um was was there a significant uh
increase in likelihood of contracting
according to this data set which is
which i don't trust suspect right right
so
all i'm saying i don't think that's
likely at all but if the result
was robust which you and i both suspect
it isn't but
if it was robust that's one of the
places i would look is is there some
behavior
that is captured by you know within
walking the dog that isn't
recorded in the data that is actually
responsible for the transmission but
sometimes it's very likely sorry in some
ways that's the same that's the same
category as my
well if you're the kind of person who
walks your dog you may be also the kind
of person who goes to dog parks
right so it's like you know what what
else is in this category
um that you'd man you didn't manage to
collect with this survey
and um you know i'd like to see the dog
walking
versus um dog walking and dog park going
and um you might like to see the dog
walking
only versus dog walking and you know
going into other businesses while in the
dog walk something like that
um i guess one other there are a few
more results i want to talk about here
but
i will also say
where is it in the conclusions of the
paper the very end of the paper
i quote the results of this study
demonstrate that living with dogs
working on site purchasing essential
commodities by using home delivery
service
and especially living with a covet-19
patient have been the main roots of
transmission of saris cov2 during the
most restrictive period of confinement
in spain
now i hope that's just like a typo
but that is exactly the opposite of the
result that they actually found in this
paper and i went back and looked at
their results and now we don't have
access to the the actual the raw data
but
the results show that pet ownership is
not correlated with
you know again if we could trust these
data but you know
every single thing we say about this
paper is if we can trust the day and we
don't that we can
but using the data that they are talking
about here they find
that pet ownership is not correlated
with increased risk of covid
19 um whereas walking your dog is and
then the conclusions they say the
opposite they say something which they
absolutely 100 found not to be true
which you know that's that's a kind of
sloppiness that is
really not okay well i i agree that the
implication of that sentence is exactly
what you say and it
uh is counter to even um the patterns
and the data they
seem to think they have found there's a
way in which
um you could defend the sentence in
other words no no you
because because they specifically talk
about pet living with pets early in the
paper
right but like this it's not even like
we didn't look at that and so we're kind
of being sloppy in our talking
this is this is a thing that they
specifically looked at and they found no
evidence of it and they say they found
evidence of it no no i get it it's
completely misleading but the fact is
dog ownership leads to dog walking and
so if dog walking
is where the transmission is happening
then dog ownership is the gateway
totally not giving them a pass here
because they say they have not given
them a pass no
they have people who say i have dogs but
i didn't walk them during the pandemic
because i was concerned right
people who have dogs who didn't walk
them show
no increased risk according to this data
set which i don't trust
but so no no like this is actually one
of the few places where they do have
granularity in terms of their categories
and then they lose that granularity and
say something that they did not find
even
in their conclusions well so here's the
problem is i mean i'm
defending a losing position because
basically no reasonable person could
interpret what they said that way but if
we go back and say what kind of error
was this i believe there's a logical
basis on which that sentence
and maybe you know i don't know if
there's a language issue here or not but
that's that's also
but it's possible that they arrived at
something that you know has a
connotation that's absolutely not
justified but that if you just look at
the
um words that one it is not a false
statement
my hope is it's a it's a translation
issue but given that they have they were
careful in the rest of the paper on this
exact issue
i don't i i can't even begin to explain
that
so um two other results
again from an analysis of a data set
the analysis of which i don't you know
the data set i don't trust and the
analysis i don't trust
but one result uh is that
public transport uh taking public
transport did have a big effect
on on transmission risk in all the
categories they looked at
including um buses trains and metros but
not taxis
interestingly so that that again is
consistent with the model that we have
that has been emerging that we've been
talking about from the beginning
which is that small enclosed spaces with
lots of people
with relatively slow clearing of the air
and lots of people breathing into it
is going to be your high risk
environment whereas a taxi
with one person with one person uh
in it at a time plus you is going to be
lower risk
well actually i'm suspicious about this
now it's possible
you could have something like there was
wisdom circulating about air circulation
and people were
opening their windows or that you know
amongst
uh taxi drivers there was uh
you know informal discussion of uh open
the windows after somebody's been
in your vehicle before the next person
gets in or whatever
there could be something that would be
protective but my sense is
even given the contact with a much
smaller number of people
that happens in a cab that a cab would
be a very
dangerous a a place where there's a high
risk of transmission and b a place where
interventions could be massively
effective
right clearing the air by opening
windows or driving around with your
windows open as we have done
that uh is liable to be highly effective
and so
i i want to know what that why the taxis
show up as anomalous there yeah
uh and one more thing uh that the result
that um
cleaning your groceries when you got
home was effective at reducing the risk
of getting the virus but wearing masks
was not
struck me as maybe the most surprising
of all well
that is of course not what they found
again data are suspect analysis is
suspect but
if the data are legit and the analysis
is
conveying conveying accurately what is
true
what they actually found is not that
mask wearing doesn't
uh protect against kova 19 but the mask
squaring outside
doesn't protect against copper19 they
specifically ask people
when you go outside do you wear masks
and those people who did
did not suffer did not experience a
greater relief from
getting covet 19 than those people who
did not guess why because it's really
hard to get this thing while outside now
that does run
counter to this dog walking conclusion
but
it's not that masks don't protect
against covet 19 that's not what they
asked right
that is not what the study asked at all
so it's like
if we were to let me try to figure out
the exact analogy it would be like
deciding that knowing how to swim is not
protective against
drowning by surveying people who were on
land
right yeah yeah people who can't swim
are no more likely to drown strange as
that sounds
amazing i guess we just all know how to
swim yeah
or something yeah that's good right um
so
yeah and that that last thing that's not
the author's fault right the
the fact that the media take this and
run with it and make scare headlines to
sell you products that you don't need
is not the fault of the authors of this
study i do think there's plenty to
critique as we've already done
about in the study um but the sort of
screaming from the headlines masks are
less effective than
cleaning your groceries when you get
home against covet 19 no
i'm not not in any way compelled and not
only that that's not even what the study
says
yep all right are you there because i
have a uh
a question for you are you there with
respect to the study or you have further
you want to go yeah i guess um maybe
just one more thing is that we
um we talk we've talked a lot about how
this virus might be evolving
and it i i've seen just a few you know i
mostly don't go and look at
you know comments and and stuff uh
responding to
what it is that we've said but i've
begun to see a few things
that suggest that people are
misunderstanding that claim to mean that
our understanding of the virus is
evolving
that is also true for sure i think
everyone on the planet understands that
that is true at this
point and that early claims that were
wrong were sometimes wrong because they
were political
and the people making them knew they
were wrong like the surgeon general
saying don't wear masks they're not
helpful that sort of thing when they had
every reason to think that they were
but certainly some of what we have
thought to be true
we now don't think to be true and that's
not because there's deceit um
going on but simply because we have a
better model now of what's true
so our understanding is evolving is one
true thing but it is also true
that the virus itself has every reason
to be evolving evolving
as it comes to infect more and more host
people
maybe other species as well across all
range of habitats and different seasons
with different amounts of indoor versus
outdoor social versus not social
engagement and so um
we should we should be thinking about
even what we really really understand to
be true
about this virus back in march and
also be asking whether or not those
things
still hold now two-thirds of a year
later yeah
that's a really important point
one caution is
what we know should go up over time
but that there is an analog to
the hazard that we described in i think
our last live stream
uh whereas something becomes rare it
becomes
uh people become increasingly sentence
sensitive and start seeing it where it
isn't
to the analysis ago i think yeah the
analog here
is that um as the virus becomes rare
then our data is increasingly polluted
by erroneous
reports in other words if the virus were
at zero then studying false reports of
it would give us a wrong sense of what
it was doing
and what kind of effects it was having
on the body so that's just something we
need to be cautious about
that's absolutely true and we actually
talked about um the sort of the early
side of that problem early on when rates
were going up
rates were still you know the number of
cases are still very low and we talked
about
um why false positives are going to
make the rate seem like it's much higher
than it is when you have a very low
background rate in the population yeah
exactly all right so are you ready for
the bonus round
yeah okay good here's the question um
this paper seems to suck really badly
do you want it retracted ah no
excellent um you have done very well in
the balance round however many points
were available you've earned them
i earned a new car uh well how about
just one we've already got
i'm happy with it okay i don't need a
new car yeah no i um
glad to hear you say that i i had little
doubt that i don't want a new car
that also yes for financial reasons but
um
no that um i know i do not want this
paper retracted no how dare you
want to happen what do i want to happen
i want conversations like this
to uh to happen in the scientific
community and not just
here um but to also have journalists
hear it
and to oh boy i want
better scientific literacy so that some
at least some of the ways that we have
dismantled this paper here
become second nature to anyone who is
looking at a paper
but the vast majority of people never
see the papers they see
the the journalism on it so science
journalists
need to freaking up their game this
needs to be
this needs to be far far better so um i
do wonder
um what what all the peer review looked
like
in this case you know how
how the presumably three anonymous peer
reviewers which is the usual the usual
model
responded to uh
to the idea that um
they had lumped diagnosed cases of covid
with people who said i probably i
suspect i have it
like what was the peer review response
and what did
or did they not catch it in which case
that's that's a yet another failure of
peer review so
i want all of those things and it's a
big broad set of things but retraction
no
would you want other papers published
that challenged the methodology here
looked at the data and figured out
whether there was anything to be seen
something like that yes and actually and
a letter to the editor of this journal
saying here's
here's five problems with this paper
please you know please
do what you can to have this sort of
come up whenever people search on this
paper right so that people can see
the the concerns yep wonderful all right
well i'm in complete agreement um
the right thing to do here is the
natural scientific thing to do which is
to take a paper that appears to be
honestly generated likely to be mistaken
in its conclusions and to challenge it
inside the modality of science um
in a in a way that um uh
is trackable right a retraction is a
very
problematic thing because we will have
had this discussion about whether or not
walking your dog
gets you sick and then suddenly the
paper vanishes from
the record as if it was never there it's
uh it's become unpapered
yes yeah yes all right so you you are
not by chance talking about this paper
here are you it is on my mind
it is honestly you want to show it
briefly yeah actually can you scroll up
i will read the abstract and the title
here
okay actually let's see oh i can see it
um the paper in question which caused a
big firestorm on twitter and elsewhere
it was published in nature one of the
two biggest science journals in the
world this week uh it's in nature
communication that's right nature
communication um so published by nature
but in a
less high profile place the title is the
association between
early career informal mentorship in
academic collaborations and junior
author performance
and this paper here i'm going to read
the abstract it says
we study mentorship in scientific
collaborations where a junior scientist
is supported
by potentially multiple senior
collaborators without them necessarily
having formal supervisory roles we
identify three million mentor protege
pairs and survey a random sample
verifying that their relationship
involved some form of mentorship we find
that mentorship
quality predicts the scientific impact
of the papers written by proteges post
mentorship
without their mentors we also find
that increasing the proportion of female
mentors is associated
not only with a reduction in
post-mentorship impact of female
proteges
but also a reduction in the gain of
female mentors
while current diversity policies
encourage same-gender mentorship to
retain
women in academia our findings raise the
possibility that opposite gender
mentorship
may actually increase the impact of
women who pursue a scientific career
these findings add a new perspective to
the policy debate
on how to best elevate the status of
women
in science well i for one am outraged
are you outraged
can't you tell well you are in good
company it seems that
um the the internet writ large has its
knickers and a twist over this
yes yes um so here's the
the problem first of all i just i i have
only skimmed this paper i have not read
it
um but but i saw some of the kerfuffle
but you saw the kerfuffle
yes um the twisted knickers kerfuffle
twisted knickers so far no fisticuffs
but i think it's coming
no that's that's once you get male
mentors on the scene i think that's how
fisticuffs come in
wow i am not touching that um okay
so a number of interesting things going
on here
the paper is complex and deals with a
complex and very large data set
there is every possibility that there
are errors in this paper
likelihood it's hard to write a paper
this complex on a topic like this
without at least some level of error
which does not suggest that this paper
is wrong in its conclusion now i would
point out though
that um the first of all
we are in a position as we have argued
here before and i'm not sure how well
people get our point
but the philosophy of science is
essential to do right even if you don't
give a damn about it right and most of
us don't really give a damn about the
philosophy of science for
its own sake but the fact is
that a result that is preceded by a
predictive hypothesis is vastly more
significant
than the same result found as a simple
matter of observation
now in the case of this paper i would
argue that these
people were accidentally testing a
hypothesis that presumably they were
just unaware of
right now i wouldn't say that their
paper is completely without a hypothesis
if you read it it appears that they are
testing the hypothesis
that female mentorship of female
proteges is enhancing of their
academic standing later in their careers
so there's a very narrow hypothesis on
the table
but those who have followed you and me
for a long time
will have heard one or both of us say
that gender is the software of sex
that that means that uh the software
is the fact of their being software of
sex
means that things that are contained in
the software layer are more easily
changed
but that it is highly likely that there
are kinds of wisdom
that have traveled a male route that is
to say
father to son uncle to nephew
there are liable to be other kinds of
wisdom that have traveled a female route
mother to daughter
uh aunt to to nice
and that to the extent that we want a
renegotiation of gender roles which you
and i have both strongly advocated for
that there might be the need for
mentorship that takes
wisdom that has traveled one of these
routes or the other and broadcast it
across that line
right this this paper which i'm not
saying the paper is right
but the paper appears to test that
hypothesis that there are things that a
female protege might
learn from a male mentor that would
increase her power in science
going forward all right so i find this
very interesting
in that light i think i actually
generated another hypothesis
for why this might be true if it is true
okay so again we've got
area yes we've got we've got a result on
the table
um i haven't spent enough time in this
paper to say whether or not
i um i trust it's it's methods etc
like i like i already went through with
the coveted paper
but if you accept this result why might
it be true let's generate some
hypotheses to explain it
you've proposed one and um which is that
basically crossing between um
traditional division of labor sex and
gender roles
such that you can get some of the wisdom
that has traditionally traveled on
on one or the other line into the other
line might be useful in terms of
becoming your best most
powerful and productive analytical
creative self that's one hypothesis as i
understand it
not exactly okay my point is so
an observation can generate a hypothesis
that then requires a test
i know i'm not telling you anything you
don't know my point is
the hypothesis that we put on the table
and i believe it's actually in
our um in our rogan uh appearance
that there are kinds of wisdom that
travel male line
kinds of wisdom that travel female and
to the extent we want to renegotiate
there needs to be some transmission of
what it is that's known in each of these
realms that the other side needs to be
aware of now so
that's my argument is that's a
pre-existing hypothesis
yes that predicts this result oh
okay so it doesn't explain it if it's
true it predicts that it's true and that
gives
that means there is reason to think that
hypothesis is accurate based on
this result if the result is robust yes
so i i guys i see what you're saying so
oh boy i mean you can you can do it both
ways it's more powerful to say
to to have it be true with that uh we
said this
earlier and didn't think to propose this
experimental model this experimental
test of that hypothesis but it does seem
to be a test of the hypothesis yep
um so mine then is a subsidiary
explanation
for this result that women
in science may do better
this result if it is true is that
women in science may do better with uh
male
mentors um which is that and this
it's related to what you were just
talking about it's not exactly the same
which is that in other primate species
and indeed in
pre-industrial human societies uh
male and female social interactions
uh were of course mixed but they were
very distinct and in
all other primate species this is 100
true male hierarchies male dominance
hierarchies and
and female dominance hierarchies there's
all this stuff in the
in the common common discourse about
alpha males and beta males and all of
this
and very little discussion about
actually there's there's a parallel but
very much not the same
dominance hierarchy among females in
baboons
in squirrel monkeys and you know in all
of these species and
in other species you also have the rules
around what are called phylopatry and
dispersal again i'm not telling you
anything you don't know
filopatry and dispersal where you know
sex-based rules where which sex at the
point that it becomes a reproductive age
disperses and goes find another group
and which sex stays in its natal clan
and whichever sex stays whichever sex is
so-called phyllopatric
tends to have um the more kin-based
rule-rich model of dominance hierarchy
be it female or male than the one
who um on the sex who's going to be
dispersing in
in that case um so anyway all of this is
true we know that is true and what we're
trying to do
in the late 20th and early 21st century
is
reconfigure some traditional rules
around
separate female and male lines of of
hierarchy in the workplace for instance
and it's not easy
it's not simple and frankly
one of the things that makes it not easy
and not simple is
that men find it pretty easy and without
thinking about it
you know just natural which is a word
that isn't great to use here but to
compete with one another
and so do women and competition between
men looks like the way we all think of
competition between men typically
looking and competition between women
doesn't look like fisticuffs it looks
more covert
it looks more about changing of social
reputation etc
but it may well be and you know
anecdotally i think i have i have seen
this not just for myself but
across many of my peers that it is
easier effectively to walk into
a situation across sex and not be seen
as a competitor right away and thus get
a more collaborative dynamic
going more easily so it's effectively a
way to cluj to get around
the older dominance hierarchies that are
within sex
and you know when will dominance
hierarchies emerge that are that are
together with both sexes of course they
will
but they're newer and we have a better
chance of more easily changing the rules
all right so uh i agree with that
although a i want to know whether it's
symmetrical
right a male walking into a
a system of females may be disruptive
of the collaborative instinct who knows
well but i don't say a system of
male like a woman walking into a system
of males and this isn't so
this study which i again i didn't read
all of it but i read a little bit of it
you know they're not looking at like phd
advisors in the graduate students they
specifically aren't they're looking at
publication records where there's a
senior author and a junior author
and looking at the sex between them
uh and so that's not
you know sometimes these papers have
eight ten forty people on them but
um and i have no idea how carefully they
looked um but in general
um they were looking at dyadic
relationships they thought they were
looking at diatic relationships which is
to say one you know one
older person a one one senior person one
junior person
and their rubric for that was just
something like you know did you get your
phd more than seven years ago or less
than seven years ago so
yeah it's a little bit it's course it's
course um
but it's not as you know it's not a man
walking into a system
you know another group of people
responding i was responding to what you
were saying about
a dynamic i wasn't talking about the
paper in that case right so
you know about the ability to generate
collaboration was what i was responding
to
um the so i i do want to say though
there's a possibility
of something more you know the reason
that the philosophy of science part
matters is that if the hypothesis
pre-exists the test right then
you know that it is not confirmation
bias right
so you know that what isn't confirmation
if if the hypothesis
comes if the hypothesis follows from the
test in other words what you really have
is an empirical observation and then a
hypothesis
and then these things are very
frequently reported as if the hypothesis
preceded the test
then the point is you haven't really
tested it you have not tested and so you
don't have the
the the power that comes from the
scientific
method in this case though if the test
is accurate and it reflects the
hypothesis that existed beforehand
even better that they didn't know about
it in some sense because they couldn't
have been responding to it or
unlikely to be then the question is what
does that say
about it reflects well on the model that
generated the hypothesis and the
prediction yep
so what does that model say one of the
things that model says
is that there is a male mode that
is actually i don't want to say integral
but is strongly consistent with
scientific progress
and that male model i'm going to argue
has to do
with what we have described as taking
the piss out of each other
that there is a way that men who view
each other as
collaborators will still you know
seek each other's weaknesses poke at
them prod them
you know there is a sort of competitive
mode
that results in you becoming
anti-fragile because
your intimate partners are finding
what's wrong with your work
so that you can take care of it before
you unveil it to the world that kind of
thing
yeah and that women have a system
i'm not saying that any of this has to
be but women have a system in which
with those they are collaborating with
there tends to be a reflexive support
a building up right a build building
people up
and so the point is that this might have
an implication
now here's the thing you had male
mentors mostly male mentors
in graduate school yes okay um
so arnold kluge dick alexander
um i had mostly male mentors also but
uh elizabeth calco stands out to me the
marvelous
she is now dead unfortunately but uh
anyway the
most extraordinary bat woman of all
who herself had been mentored by charles
handley um
so anyway here's the thing if this paper
is accurate
and it correctly reveals that the
hypothesis
that was on the table which is that
there are male and female kinds of
wisdom that have been transmitted and
that they have to be transmitted across
in order to
bring everyone in on the endeavor
then this predicts some further things
right
oh i i should point out the second
result here is kind of interesting too
which was that mentoring females
appeared to have a cost to the mentors
going forward also
so that actually yes so that actually is
suggestive
of a mechanism here which is to say that
the dynamic between mentor and mentee
um might be less effective
um in other words if you imagine just as
a placeholder so are you sure about that
result did you you didn't get that from
the abstract did you no i think i did
so you have a reduction in the gain of
female mentors
right for the mentees yeah that's not
that that to me does not read as
a cost to me well we will have to go
back and find i think that's what it
does mean
but um but anyway um
where were we sorry to distract no
that's okay
uh in any case one way or the other what
this predicts going forward if the model
is accurate
and this is a proper test of it which is
robust then it predicts
actually that the effect will decay over
time
that is to say that females who have
been mentored by males and gotten the
benefited
benefit of it will be better mentors to
females that they mentor in the future
right so second order male mentorship
yeah i mean i hate to put it that way
because i don't think it's like that men
deserve
credit for it but what i do think is
that the answer
look you and i well and and you know if
if my obs if my hypothesis is correct
which i
expect it to be i'm not sure but i
expect it also to be weaker
than what you're talking about but if it
is true then it would also go in the
opposite direction
and so you would have a benefit to a
potential benefit
uh to men being mentored by women but
you could have second order female
mentorship in which a man who had been
mentored by a woman
might be um might be you know less
competitive say
with his male mentees than he would be
if he had been mentored by a man himself
yeah and certainly this being a complex
system you would expect many such
effects to be
over layered with each other and
figuring out which ones you know
had what strength of effect would be you
know a whole line of inquiry that might
might arise here yeah um so i'm reminded
but you're going no go ahead um i'm
reminded of the conversation i had uh
with with tom on impact theory this week
which i don't think is out yet but um i
was on his podcast this week and we were
talking a little bit about
about sex and gender and roles in the
workplace and he
said um he's a very successful
entrepreneur he said
i tom when i'm leading teams that are
entirely male
it's much easier for me but when i'm
leading teams that are mixed sex they're
more productive
and this is something i kept coming back
to throughout our conversation i thought
that you know that
that is a beautiful observation and i
kind of hope it holds
right it doesn't surprise me that it's
easier if it's all if it's all one sexy
and
you know he basically he used some of
this kind of language that you know he i
don't think he said
we take the piss out of each other he's
like i can i could tell
you know my my teammates even when i'm
the leader that they're being fuck-ups
and they need to up their game
and it's expected and if i don't do that
then they have no way to know
and the the work on mixed sex teams is
slower
and i have to be thinking about these
people's feelings in a way i don't have
to be thinking about these people's
feelings and it's it's a lot more
chaotic but
but he asserts and this is not you know
he's not being politically correct
he asserts that they are ultimately more
productive now
so i've got two things i want to get to
and i don't want to forget either of
them
one of them is that that is suggestive
of
an analog of hybrid vigor and this is
another point that i think we've been
hinting around and we've made a couple
times but i really want it to be
explicit
so hybrid vigor is the recognition and
this is
this comes from breeding this is
actually a genetic phenomenon in
uh artificial selection of things like
farm animals
that you take two purebred critters and
you breed them together they often have
extraordinary capacity relative to their
parents right and there can be a number
of reasons for this
one purebreds may be hobbled by being
purebreds in other words the inbreeding
that comes along with
getting a pure line can be destructive
and so this can be liberating of that
but it also can be that there are
advantages to borrowing from two
millions
so to the extent that there is male and
female wisdom and you have a team
in which people are native to both of
these languages
that team potentially if you can figure
out how to get it not to trip over
itself
has both modes available yes yes
and so okay so the last point i want to
make here
is an awful lot of what is going on
in academia is based on the assertion
that the characteristics of the person
at the front of the room
dictate whether or not the students and
the chairs are going to be effectively
able to learn from them
unless you see somebody who looks like
you at the front of the room you've got
a problem
right now my point would be that is
nonsense that it's not to say there's no
component of truth in it
i think that there is a going to be some
positive effect of having somebody you
very easily identify with
at the front of the room and some
component of that will be based on
superficial characteristics
but the idea that you should upend a
faculty
in order to get people at the front of
the room who look like the students
which is by the way crazy because the
students don't tend to look like each
other so
how do you even do it without
segregating right charmerism
right but um but the idea that we should
be
refactoring the world so that you know
the most important thing is that the
people at the front of the
room have the same skin color or sexual
orientation or whatever it is
they're sacrificing academic rigor for a
failure of imagination on the part of
students
right and you're also potentially
sacrificing even to the extent that the
world looks the way it does because of
unfairness
to the extent that some people have the
insight into how the work gets done if
you want to make the world fair
whatever they know has to be
democratized right and in some sense
that's going to make for very
uncomfortable conclusions like
you know you might want to you know have
a male mentor if you're female because
it it's going to make you a stronger
competitor going forward in a world
where
some large fraction of the people you're
dealing with are male i i don't know
that that's where it comes from but
that's at least a
viable possibility so
anyway oh but the final conclusion here
is that the demand
by those who are outraged by this is
that the paper be
retracted right and yes there are some
valid concerns that are raised about the
methodology of the paper as there
always are it is not hard to take
almost any paper of any complexity and
find things that
weren't done well that open the
possibility of some other explanation
it's very hard to do perfect work right
it almost never happens
but it appears that there is this
motivation to find anything and
everything wrong with this paper in
order to justify the claim that it is so
bad that not only does it need to be
challenged
but it needs to be retracted because the
damage that comes from it
and this is so much the ethos of the
moment where you know a paper that is
wrong
has to be held accountable for its error
whether or not that was the intent
because after all harm
is the you know the end all and be-all
and people are certainly going to be
harmed
by the idea that you know that one
might wonder about whether or not you
know wisdom is
being properly transmitted based on the
sex of the
mentor right so anyway i i just think
this is emblematic of everything we're
seeing
yeah no i think you're right it's it's
conclusion driven and
this the methodology is flawed therefore
you must retract
line of activists is becoming is
becoming the go-to line right it's
exactly the one they used against lisa
littman's work on rapid onset gender
dysphoria which is
i believe the uh term that she actually
um
introduced in the paper in question and
um i believe in that case i don't
remember the specifics that it was
pulled and she did revise
and it went back out and almost nothing
changed
and so you know the the journal was able
to basically say that they had caved to
the activists and the work is still out
there because it was
it was good work and it's important work
but anyway the point
there being and like here there's
literally no information at all
in a claim there are methodological
flaws in a paper that's yes
and you know too bad and that's part of
what the peer review process is supposed
to be about and to find and
papers that are deeply flawed should not
be published etc etc etc
but in this era the claim that there are
methodological problems
is simply another activist tactic and
should be treated as such
yeah which is which is a shame because
legitimate methodological flaws that
were not caught in peer review
do warrant a very careful um critique
um and you know and thought about
whether or not a paper should have been
published but
that's not what's going on no it's not
and i would just say
even if your bent is that this is all
about
structural unfairness in the system one
interpretation of the paper is that it
has
unearthed a serious kind of structural
unfairness right
to the extent that this result is robust
right it now
invites a conversation about what might
be causing it and it may be
kinds of wisdom that need to be
transmitted in various ways it may be
just
purely the bias of people downstream who
don't take you seriously if you had a
female mentor who knows
but the point is if it's a result
that's if the result is robust then you
know
it tells us there's a phenomenon that we
need to be finding
yeah there's a phenomenon that we need
to be finding the conversation needs to
be allowed to be had
uh if you stop the conversation by
retracting a paper these conversations
will continue to be had they'll just be
underground out of you by the activists
and and and get stronger frankly i hope
um but you know those two let's see you
just said two possible mechanisms of
explanation
um one of which is what we've been
talking about and one of which is well
maybe it's about you know the bias of
people downstream who don't take you as
seriously if you had a female mentor
i think that doesn't apply here because
we're not actually talking about the
standard
definition of mentor we're talking about
people who've published um with people
as opposed to
being their phd advisors but take that
standard model well
you can what i was saying was didn't
doesn't
it's not sensitive to which kind of
mentor in other words if people in your
little field are aware of who you've
published with that could potentially be
a factor
sure okay i guess i guess so um
i think if i'm it's really hard to steal
man
this position here um but if
if i'm gonna try to steal man their
position i would say
it's absolutely critical that um
you know even if we are reasonable human
beings that we can grant
that there are different kinds of wisdom
that have tended to travel on the male
and female lines and we would like
cross-pollination between them and
therefore
there might be benefit to having men and
women working together hey look at that
it is still it is deplorable and
abhorrent and we must stop immediately
in its tracks the bias
that is simply um you know opposed to
someone on the basis of some immutable
demographic characteristic
stopping this conversation because some
people will use it to justify
that bias i think is what is going on in
their heads and see i did a terrible job
of stealing that because i
can't do it but i but i do think that
even though probably almost none of the
activists know that that's what they're
scared of
it's that it's this result will be used
to justify
a bias and what they've imagined is the
only explanation for
this being beneficial is bias and it's a
little bit like
you know the four to one ratio of male
to female software engineers at google
it must be biased that's the only
possible explanation
no no there are many other possible
explanations
and i believe strongly that most of them
have
far more explanatory power than bias is
there still bias
presumably yes should we be trying to
eradicate it
obviously should we not talk about it in
order to not give anyone any sense that
there's bias
or like what what was that how did you
even get there right so i
so the activist response is actually
counterproductive even to
their honorable goals and as to their
dishonorable goals i don't know why
we're playing games with them at all
yeah um so the whole thing
a i would say you know there are lots of
cruddy there are lots of people who
aren't very good
up in the upper echelons of science and
certainly in
the vast ranks of those doing science
that said the work
is subtle and there is a great deal that
is learned
as somebody who figures out how to wield
these tools properly
comes to that knowledge and the
activists are involved
in a response to it
as if there was nothing there and their
basic point is look we can spot the
truth
we know what the truth is and so if you
come up with a paper that's offensive
relative to this model that is the truth
then of course you should retract it why
would we want anything but the truth in
these scientific journals
the answer is you don't know what you're
freaking talking about you have no idea
how complex things like sociality
are and therefore you know how messy the
truth is going to be
and the real question that they you know
don't seem willing to ask is
you know if we had the truth which we
don't yet
right we won't ever fully get there it's
a diminishing returns problem but if we
had the truth
how bad is it now my sense having spent
all of my adult life in this game
is the truth is messy but it's actually
way better than it could be
right in fact these problems are
solvable but we're never going to get
there
if we're you know fighting over whether
or not we are allowed to consider
the mess right so anyway i think i'm
ready to get off my soapbox but um
but there it is all right uh well i
actually think the next topic
uh is is related to this which is
about muir woods and the queering of the
national park service which i can't even
say without getting tense
rubbing my thigh there um so here we go
uh excuse me why is nothing working
zach would you show my screen here for a
moment i came to be aware of this when
colin wright our friend colin wright
who's
um another uh animal behaviorist
evolutionary biologist like we
are rights you the world is going mad
everything is politicized i'm starting
to think twitter's real life i should
take heather hein's advice to go outside
take
a walk in the woods and just get away
from it all for a bit to clear my head
the woods say and here he's got a
picture for those listening not
observing
um on some your woods is this glorious
woods just north of the golden gate
bridge in marin county in california
that we have spent some time in as
adults and i spent time in as a child
and just just glorious redwood coastal
redwoods
it says muir woods queer woods
muir woods is highlighting queer ecology
and the new perspectives it gives us in
this forest
queer ecology is the study of
reimagining how people think about
nature
it studies gender sexuality and behavior
in the natural world
queer ecology questions the way people
categorize nature into binaries or boxes
for instance i'm a lighting here some
boxes queer ecology challenges
are male female natural unnatural
and human nature
when was a time you saw something a new
light it says
so um i'm going to give this sign credit
where it's due which is not much um
the categories of natural and unnatural
and human nature
are indeed very fuzzy um
not useful categories within science
particularly
and we should mostly drop them male
female
is not in that group zach can i have my
um screen back thank you sweetie
um so oh god first let's talk about what
it means to queer something
shall we shall we um
so um james lindsay's new discourses
has a good description there
that page says as an and this is um this
is
their description from sources of what
the actual people who talk about
queering things say it is so this is
in sort of the scholar activists words
quote as an activist framework
queer functions as a verb to queer is to
challenge the dominance of heterosexist
discourses
or is quote a distorting a making the
solid unstable
to put it another way queering is a
complicating of the taken for granted
heteronormativity
of everyday practices spaces and
discourses
sign me up
so this reminds me actually there's a
there's a lot that i want to get to here
but this reminds me of
the kind of naive knee-jerk
thing that i understand was happening in
silicon valley
maybe even now but really in the arts
and those sort of late aughts
around disruption disrupt it that's what
we're going to do we're going to disrupt
the thing right we're going to disrupt
everything and
it's just it's just this blanket impulse
to mess with things that appear to be
functional because sometimes
when you mess with things that appear to
be functional one of a couple of useful
things can happen sometimes it
reveals that that thing that appeared to
be functional wasn't functional at all
and was being
held it was some sort of a potemkin
thing that was just a facade and
there was nothing real behind it and
sometimes it was functional but only by
destroying it can you actually get to
something more functional and more
interesting so
those two things are real possibilities
right but
just disrupting to disrupt i mean that's
what's going on in the streets of
portland with the riots this is this is
this is simply a ridiculous approach
to seeing that there are things in the
world that you disagree with
because guess what you know this
challenging scientific orthodoxy that's
built into the scientific method
that's what we do that is that is what
we do heterodoxy
and orthodoxy are in this this constant
tension with one another
and yeah it's hard to get
the the fast held beliefs out
and um apparently it's uh disputed as to
who originally framed this but you know
max planck
apparently originally said something in
a longer-winded form
um that progress in science advances
funeral by funeral and that wasn't
that's not actually his language but
um the idea being that even when
something new is discovered
the old guard doesn't want to see that
it's true because their entire careers
are built on something
that is that is different and so you
need to some degree unfortunately this
is an unfortunate social truth
of how it is that we come to understand
and accept what is true
um that some some people need to die
before you know rather than ever
accepting it
yeah i wanna there's a big asterisk that
needs to be there
come back to it but the
you can have a culture of science in
which even
those who are entrenched in a mindset
because they've lived their entire
career
are of a mind to find what's wrong with
it and if it is incorrect
to get to the correct place as quickly
as possible and unfortunately it is the
economics of the way we do science
in the modern era that makes this um
so rare but to the extent that what one
is trying to do
is come up with things that are right
enough that they are very lasting and
maybe
you know the ultimate expression of that
is something that is so right
that it is permanently recorded as true
right
that that incentive is very very
different than an incentive a careerist
incentive which we use as a proxy and it
is the careers
incentive that is wrecking science yes
well it's no
that's absolutely right that is i would
say that's one of the incentives that is
wrecking science
uh maybe the uh financial incentives
associated with
nsf and nih are sub incentives below
that
um but so you know thomas kuhn writing
in a different era
in in the 60s when he wrote the
structure of scientific revolutions
pointed this out and actually he also um
brought up plonk's observation um in
talking about paradigm shifts and
talking about and you know the way that
i've framed this
both when i'm teaching philosophy of
science um but just in in everyday life
is that you you know there
there are a lot of ways to categorize
the different types of science and one
of them
is you can do sort of brick in the wall
science where you assume that your
foundation is solid and you're doing
something that's going to create another
little little piece
that supports the foundation and the
wall that's already being built
but you excuse me you build that wall a
little bit higher
or you can do something that is paradigm
shifting
and um and you don't want to be doing
like most people don't have it in them
to do paradigm shifting science
um they mostly don't have it in them
most people to do paradigm shifting
science but
that doesn't mean that if your
foundation is unstable there's
any justification for doing brick in the
wall science most of the science being
done is brick in the wall science
if the foundation is solid that's good
you're you know it's sort of you know
it's worker b
science that's great um only if the
foundation is solid but of course you
then get all the worker bees up in arms
at the point that someone is trying to
destroy the foundation
that is how this works this like this
this this bringing in of heterodoxy into
orthodoxy and science
not through flat out disruption and
queering the woods
and all this other garbage that simply
is
confused about what we actually know is
lying about what it does
know that we know and is looking to
destroy
frankly you know everything associated
with science and and discourse about it
um the fact that this shows up here
uh and so i don't know what queer
ecology is because it didn't exist when
we were
um studying uh in grad school and
these i've got a partial answer for you
oh you do oh do you want to go there now
um before you uh yeah sure um
let's see so this this sign was posted
by the national park service
the sign that we just showed you and it
also and said in fine print at the
bottom
um that this exhibit is federal property
destroying or removing it is a
misdemeanor punishable by a fine of up
to a hundred thousand dollars one year
imprisonment or both
wait what exhibit this science i believe
i believe right so that that itself is
a little terrifying okay um even if
there's a strong argument to be made
that you are in fact
queering that sign by removing it
yes yes that will be the argument
in court i think that will be my defense
and it will fall on
completely deaf ears i have the sense
but nonetheless
yes um so uh national park park service
excuse me did have a ridiculous page
supporting these claims but
um here we go just briefly zach here's
what's happened to that page
um they've taken it down page in
progress i'm not sure i would define it
as progress
um but then on a separate access into
the nps site the national park service
um they have a video uh and i don't
come on um i'm not sure here actually oh
we probably can't
yeah um so i'll just i will tell you
what some of
is being said here this is um a
someone who's not identified as a part
guy but a gay part guide
talking about queer ecology and what
he says
is that speaking for the national park
service
he says that male and female are quote
boxes that humans have constructed
he then um provides as evidence he's got
a few more
park guides who identify as things like
lesbian park ranger
and and such like they all have these
adjectival
things in front of their description
that would actually allow them to speak
smartly about things like redwood trees
so the evidence
in this video put out by the national
park service
for the claim that male and female are
boxes that humans have constructed
include
these three things you ready i'm sitting
down you are sitting down okay the three
pieces of evidence that hum male and
female are boxes that humans have
constructed
are plants are capable of asexual
reproduction
quote this process of reproduction is
not the male female story it is the
redwood story
that's a quote okay okay that's one
piece of evidence male and female are
boxes humans have constructed two second
piece of evidence
banana slugs are hermaphrodites
point of order hermaphrodite means
you've got male and female on one body
to define hermaphrodite you need to use
the concepts
that are real of male and female also it
is debatable
uh whether or not humans actually
constructed banana slugs
all right sorry i'm having trouble
taking this seriously i i will do better
this is exactly it and then the third i
actually it's like a five and a half
minute video and i actually didn't get
to the end
but so there may actually be more
evidence but the third piece of evidence
that i was able to get through in this
video
um that
the evidence that male and female are
boxes of humans have constructed we have
plants have asexual reproduction
there are hermaphrodites in nature and
same-sex interactions exist
again debatable and the example is i kid
you not 22 species of bats and 25
species of butterflies engage in
same-sex interactions i just i don't
even know what that means like i don't
even know if they're talking about like
homosexual
interactions and i'm not sure they are
but they don't even say that right
and they've got pictures of like
butterflies just hanging out together i
this whole thing is so insane and this
is the national park service
this is the national park service they
they need
they need our help they need someone's
help this is this is ridiculous
well okay at the risk of creating
a larger firestorm then then we
otherwise
might i would point out that there has
always been something a bit
fishy over in the discipline of ecology
and oh boy you're going there i i have
no choice and i will say that some of my
favorite people in fact some people i
consider
mentors have been excellent ecologists
excellent ecologists exist but it is
also the case
that a large number of people who arrive
in
biology graduate school and decide to
study
ecology are motivated not so much by a
desire to figure out what's true
as a desire to do good in the world
which i think we have to respect doing
good in the world is a
powerful and noble mode of motivation
but it is a terrible motivation
inside of science because what it does
is it tends to get you to do things like
discount conclusions that are awkward
and elevate conclusions that may be
false but go in the proper direction
for whatever your political ideology is
so if you're wondering what the hell i
might be talking about
i will remind you heather
of the recurrent incident which
continued to be
broadcast and spread after we were long
out of graduate school
where ecologists would survey
things like textbooks for
incidents of the word cooperation and
incidence of the word
uh competition and then they would
compare these two numbers
and conclude i kid you not that these
books were biased
to a certain degree based on the the
excess
of instances of the word competition
over
cooperation and then as i recall now
i first time i encountered this i was a
young graduate student hanging out in
ecology labs listening to what was being
said but the claim was that the reason
for the bias in these textbooks
was capitalism that
i thought you were going to say the
patriarchy i was ready for that oh what
do you think capita
capitalism is just the friendly side of
the goddamn patriarchy we all
know that but um well you know that at
your meetings but i'm not invited
it is it never never needs to be said at
the at the meetings of the patriarchy
but um but the point is look
sorry to break it to you but competition
is
more fundamental than cooperation which
isn't to say that cooperation isn't
fascinating and
its study isn't vitally important but
the fact is you can
you can build an ecosystem with no
collaboration in it
you can't build one without competition
in it just the simple fact that you have
built creatures which will use up the
resources that they have
will reinstitute competition every
single time
no matter what and nobody has to
collaborate with anybody else
so the point is there is something over
in ecology space
where do gooderism gets mixed in with
science and what you get
you know next thing you know you're
you're queering forests
yeah well um two things oh wait a second
yeah you know what they're doing they're
queer cutting
oh god oh boy yep
okay i said it i feel pretty good about
it now we'll see if i'm cancelled
[Laughter]
okay two things um i don't want to say
in response to what you just said oh
a statistical point about um i remember
when you came home from the seminar
where you first heard
that that amazing uh thing that some of
our peers in graduate school had done
surveying textbooks for the words
competition and cooperation and
concluding that they're that that the
fact that competition showed up more
than
cooperation demonstrated a bias
in the people writing the textbooks and
indeed and the scientists um
they at the time i believe that you
reported that they had even done a
statistical analysis oh yes and that
they had done a chi-square test
chi-square test is maybe my favorite
statistical test and
okay it's a little weird that i have a
favorite statistical test but in part i
love it because
you really can do it on the back of an
envelope you can actually do it by hand
and you just need like one little table
of
of of critical values to compare your
result to so it's it's it's
easy and with the right kind of
experimental design you can actually
like in the field know whether or not
you found something that
might be significant but it is of a
class
of tests of a bigger class of tests
called goodness of fit tests right
goodness of fit tests are basically
um a an explicit attempt to compare your
observed values the values of that you
have recorded by going in the field and
taking data
to values that you expected to get and
seeing if your observed values match
your expected values if they did
then there's sort of no pattern to
explain and if they didn't then there's
something to explain and hopefully it's
your hypothesis if you've designed the
test well enough
that explains that pattern they used a
goodness of fit test
to assess whether or not cooperation and
competition were showing up at the
appropriate levels in these textbooks
i would put a lot of money on the idea
that their
expected results that the effectively
the
hypothesis that they went in with which
they turned into an assumption that they
based the entire analysis on
was that these two things being you know
pretty common
out there in the world should have been
showing up at equal rights in these
textbooks
exactly what they did right so you there
is no
way that you should assume that
cooperation and competition
are showing up at equal rates in the
world
and them assuming that means that they
that they didn't do science right that
they that they actually
didn't do science and they fed their
assumptions in so that the only thing
they could find
was what they did find and they also
didn't use the statistics right they
broke the assumptions
of the statistics all of which happens a
lot
in published science and it's terrible
and i wish that people were doing better
science all the time
but yeah so that's my little statistical
rant for the moment well
i mean look this is so first of all i
should say
i certainly tried to point out the
problem um
even in that i mean i believe this was
first year grad school and you know
you're circulating
in different labs to see which labs are
doing something you might be interested
in joining in on and that kind of thing
and you know it was just obvious this
made no sense and
right i wasn't smart enough yet to know
that if i said that bad things would
happen
but i'm not sure you are yet
that's also probably true but um but
anyway i did
try to point this out and it would seem
an obvious point
that once if you had if you had missed
it on the front on the first pass
it would seem that all that has to
happen is that it would be pointed out
and be like oh yeah of course
right but that is not what happens and i
i don't i'm hesitant to connect this
back to our last conversation
about different kinds of wisdom but the
point is
you want the people with whom you are
collaborating
in science to do you the favor
of pointing out what's wrong in your
work yes and then
by the time that you go out there into
the scary world and you give your talk
in front of a bunch of people you don't
know
you've already been through what's wrong
with it and you've gotten rid of the
vulnerabilities
and you have the answers to the
questions they are likely to ask
but if on the other hand you take this
um noble instinct to make the world
better by finding all of the conclusions
that are friendly
right what you end up doing is you
create massive vulnerability because you
don't even know
what's true anymore and so yeah you know
at some level this is just a dumb battle
between people who you know prioritize
what's true in spite of the fact that a
good deal of it may be awfully awkward
right and people who reverse those
priorities and the fact is you do not
want people who reverse those priorities
in charge of
truth-seeking they can't be it will
drive you mad and that's where we are
and earning credentials that give them
authority to say that they're scientists
and therefore speaking as
if they are being scientific when
they're not right yeah
and after all i mean you know the
[Music]
what conclusion are we dodging here with
the queering
of various woods right
we're dodging something as simple as
male and female
are real categories that have existed
for hundreds of millions of years that
we
humans find ourselves with this pattern
inflicted on us in a highly unique way
male and female in human beings is not
like other examples it's a it's a very
different
phenomenon and it's also a phenomenon
that is so heavily based in software
that is much more amenable to us
reworking it based on our values
than it would be if we were any other
species so that's great news
we're dodging this great news in order
to just like
force the truth to do what we want so we
don't have to deal with the complexity
of it and it's
madness yeah and i mean just really
incoherent
you know redwood burls prove that female
and male are
human constructs no
male and female are 1.2 billion years
old
in our lineage at least 500 million
years old
not new not about us this is a this is
religious fanaticism and incoherent
religious fanaticism at that
it it's it's destructive i can't believe
it's coming for the forest
and um and
i hope i hope someone does take that
sign down
um i hope they get away with it yeah
so just one more thing on this
ridiculous topic and i suspect we're way
over an hour at this point
um yeah one more thing on this topic and
then i i wanted to finish just by
talking a tiny bit about gratitude if i
may excellent
um but first i am not grateful for the
hashtag
lgbtq stem day which showed which
apparently lgbtq stem day was
on november 18th i was lucky enough not
to run into it on the day of
i'm not sure so zach don't show my
screen yet i'm gonna ask
uh your dad here if he thinks i should
sh i'm going to read this um but i'm not
sure
what do you think should i show this
it's gonna take me a second to process
it okay
um so this person says a day late uh
this is a tweet
a day late on hashtag lgbtq stem day but
i think it's important to be visible
because so often academics and
scientists try to minimize my queerness
under some false sense of impartiality
but the fact is that my queerness
matters to my work and it matters to how
i do
science i'm proud of that so i don't
think we need to show that but
um that is a sentiment
that so perfectly capstones the
conversation that we just had
and it's so dangerous the idea that your
queerness
matters to how you do science if that's
true you're not doing science
your queerness whatever that might mean
may well impact the kinds of questions
you are interested in looking at
cool all of our biases our personal
histories
our developmental weirdnesses affect
what our preferences are
and how it is that we view the world and
therefore what we're interested in
and preferences drive
and market forces unfortunately but
preferences should be driving what kinds
of questions scientists ask
once you're actually doing the science
though once you've actually decided okay
i'm going to look into this question
nothing about your queerness or your
lesbianness
or the fact that you're from idaho or
bangalore
or that you're disabled or that you're
tall or that you're pink or that you're
black or anything
should have anything to do with how you
do your science if it does you're not
doing science
that's it's not science if you're
letting your adjectival descriptors
affect how you're doing the work inside
of the science
it affects what questions you ask it
will sure
and i would rather it not be driving
whole uh
whole endeavors like i'm gonna i'm gonna
see about investigating this from you
know
i'm gonna see what kinds of questions
might be asked with a with a queer eye
right i don't think that's particularly
honorable but okay
once the question's asked though once
you're involved in trying to answer a
question scientifically
none of these things that are true about
you should have any effect on how you're
doing the work
and um what we have said elsewhere
is that the value of science
comes from the fact that it corrects
bias
to the extent that you see bias as
integral to it
you know it's the opposite of science
science is the thing
that tells you what's true in spite of
what you may expect or want to be true
and if you rob it of that capacity then
i mean we're heading into a dark age
and many people have now observed this
um i've been saying it for
decades now that this was dawning a dark
age is dawning because we are
taking the liberty of correcting
the scientific record rather than just
recording what it's telling us and
grappling with its implications yeah
all right okay one one last thing then
yep all right
so back in march thanksgiving is coming
up
right and back in march we had no
idea most of us that we might still be
stuck in covet lockdowns and um
you know possible ends in sight but um
you know our children for instance have
not seen the inside of the classroom
since march
and who knows when that will change
um i posted this thread this was
actually before our first live stream
and i just i just want to read it and
then invite everyone else to think about
what they're grateful for because all of
these things i am still grateful for now
and maybe even more so
i created a hashtag gratitude in the
time of coronavirus
an invisible path from march 18th an
invisible pathogen races around the
planet
as we self quarantine to slow its spread
many of us feel more isolated than we
could have imagined
and yet the global nature of the threat
proves that we are all in this together
i am most grateful for all the usual
things my husband and children
all of my family my friends my health
our health i am grateful to have a
comfortable bed
in a warm house in a beautiful place
i am grateful that clean water comes out
of my tap and i am grateful that it
warms when i ask that of it
i am grateful for the utilities that
keep the water flowing and the
appliances running and the device is
charged
i am grateful for the ability to cook
and for delicious nourishing food i am
grateful for good coffee and rich cream
and a handmade mug
i am grateful for the luxury of bespoke
drinks
i am grateful for humor and here i quote
tweet
someone who says work from home tips
have a routine
shower dress like normal keep a
dedicated workspace
fill a briefcase with sausages and carry
it at all times
stick to usual work hours never let
raccoons trick you into twisting them
with a beefcase
they do not have your interests at heart
my next tweet in this thread is i am
grateful for the animals with whom i
share my life
even when they resemble raccoons working
at angle to get into my beef case
i am grateful for beauty i am grateful
for books
i am grateful for music i am grateful to
have a beautiful functional bicycle
built for me by my also beautiful
functional husband
i am grateful that taking this bicycle
out into the world will continue to be
possible in the coming weeks and months
i am grateful for soil and plants and
gardens and gardening
i am grateful for spring i hope it comes
back
i am grateful for nature and here i
quote tweeted
myself from five days earlier on march
13th in which i said
engage in social distancing to help
flatten the curve but don't nature
distance
walk in the woods and parks and
mountains and on the coast keep your
distance from other people but not from
the sun and fresh air
get and keep your body moving don't put
your body in lockdown
correction i am grateful for most of
nature not mosquitoes mostly or leeches
or ticks or fleas or plasmodium malaria
and not coronaviruses still
this leaves an awful lot to be grateful
for and there is more
so much more what are you grateful for
that's hashtag gratitude in the time of
coronavirus
where we have thanksgiving in a few days
and we will be
having it as we always do with our boys
this time
only with our boys and and our animals
um
i am i am so grateful for this life that
we have together yeah
it is remarkable um so if i may
riff briefly on that beautiful sequence
uh i was charged with writing the
forward to
a famous photographer's book this week
and it caused me to think a lot um i
am an amateur photographer but i was
looking at the amazing photographs in
this book
many things that you and i have never
seen in person
so beautifully captured and
i was moved to think about the fact
that this moment in time not
just the incredible accident of our
being present on this planet and being
creatures that are capable of
understanding what it means to be
present on this planet and what else
might be here but just the simple fact
that
modernity allows us to know about
the many wonders of the world in a way
that even a few hundred years ago
you couldn't have known what was here
even if you had reports
of what was here it was very difficult
to separate fact from fiction
and so you were left with kind of um
rumors of earth and that there is
something about
the technology which is often
frustrating and is obviously in some
sense driving us mad but that technology
is also giving us a great gift which is
the ability
to know what's here and for this brief
moment that we are present
cognizant on earth to have access to
some large fraction of the marvelous
things that are out there
i think is um it's an amazing gift and
we just don't
we don't think of it because it feels
like okay well you're on earth it's a
big diverse place and it always has been
but no
even though it was most people never
knew and
and we can yeah we have access to much
more than we have
and hopefully we will have access again
to much of it in person
soon but but right now we have access a
tremendous amount
over over the airwaves as it were yes
and
hopefully people will
realize what it is that we are putting
something at stake that it is not our
right to destroy
and the recognition of almost no matter
what
the gift that life is even under
terrible circumstances the gift of
having uh life for a time and being able
to tune in on this strange planet and
to you know to partner with other
members of your species and all of that
that that is such an amazing opportunity
that i think we have an absolute moral
obligation to attempt to deliver it in
as high a quality as we can to as many
people going forward as we can
and that that really uh
it forces one issue to the top of the
list above all others
and that is how how well are we
preserving this
and the answer is terribly and
we must do better yeah
uh when i wrote that thread that i read
we were only a couple of months
out from having been in the amazon we
spent a couple of weeks in january of
this year
at tipputini tippettini biodiversity
station
a research station deep in the ecuador
and amazon
at what has been measured to be the most
biodiverse spot on the planet
and it's one of my absolute favorite
places on earth
and uh um we
we may dedicate an episode coming up or
more even to talking about it
um but the founder and director of
of tippatini recently reached out to me
again we're friends all of us are
friends
um uh to say
it's it's suffering and it's not just
suffering in the way that we saw it
suffering where we were beginning to see
declines
in um in insectivorous birds for
instance where
like we've only been there a few times
over a relatively short span of time
just years not decades and we can
determine we can discern a decline and
decline in butterflies and decline in a
lot of the clades
that's true bats yep um
but also now there's um not only is
there pressure from
from oil drilling and you know the
financial pressures
um but there's also uh financial
pressure just from the university
sponsors
who are saying we're not sure that we
see the value
in in having people go spend time in
nature and learning what kind of
diversity there is
so um yeah we will be talking about this
and
we hope we hope to do something
that can help turn turn that tide in
some way we must
um i will say it's the i think the third
time we've seen
a version of the same myopia right
the the decision that natural history
was somehow not fully scientific or
worthy of investment
um seems you know at a bean counter
level seems very reasonable right
natural history
sounds like stories but it doesn't
require big expensive equipment and so
doesn't bring in big grants
yep but it's actually the way you figure
out what you might be missing in nature
that the patterns that you can see in
the way
creature's function uh you know it's the
in some sense the root of of good um
natural science um but we've seen it
also
in you know we we were mentored in the
museum of zoology
at at michigan and the museum of zoology
was a very quirky
weird place i mean it was an actual
museum with a you know public exhibit
side and then
floors of uh of science research going
on
and row after row dead lizards and jars
that sort of thing yeah row after row of
creatures that had been collected
and at some point the um the school
decided to ship those things off because
the collections seemed to be an expense
that
wasn't justifying itself and again it's
the same myopia which is that
you don't necessarily see the role that
these things are playing in
progress and so you make some sort of
expedient decision that's
catastrophic to something but you you
know because the connection is not
explicit
you don't spot it yeah i mean let's
let's talk about museums
more for sure in another episode um just
to be clear they did not get rid of the
collections they just they moved them to
an off-site location where they're hard
to access and no one runs into them
you can't you know they no longer act
like a library you can't sort of
walk through if you're a graduate
student or professor
and look and say oh i didn't know i
didn't know that was in
south africa or whatever it is um so
um just like moving just like the
decline of stacks of actual physical
books and being able to wander stacks in
a library
has real effects on um the nature of
discourse and intellectual
uh progress so too will the um
hiding behind lock and door lock and key
the specimens involved in zoological
collections
almost certainly affect what kinds of
questions people come to ask
yeah so there's probably a name for it
but uh
i think maybe in that discussion we
should figure out what the category is
of things that are essential but because
they are not
um visible in the progress
are often dispensed with oh yeah um
because it seems to me that that's a key
to what is going wrong in many different
places and you know we see it with the
philosophy of science
with uh hypothesis testing with
proper scientific theory um all of these
things
along with natural history museums
library stacks
and uh it would be it'd be cool to
to see how far we can get on that topic
yeah definitely
all right are we done i think we are in
the first half
that was a long first half long first
half we should have warned you up top
to file your questions for the second
half um also like subscribe notify
comment shake your fists at us whatever
you have to do you know
just do it join us join us at our
patreons if you will
um there's a discord server you can
access to there with
what i hear is some very good
conversations
um you can also go to either of our
websites to sign up if you want to be
notified
when our book is available for pre-order
it's not going to be published until
the second half of next year but it is
it is in
well underway at this point um
the clips channel is alive and well and
various other things oh and you can
always
email darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
for any logistical questions like how do
i pose a question when is the private q
a that sort of thing
yeah or if there's something we've said
that you think needs to be cleared
that would be the route in ah yes try
queering the darkhorse moderator first
see how far you get with that probably
not very but um
but go for it all right we'll see you
shortly be well
you